i could not be happier about this i
think the entire government should be
privatized
chuck e cheese could run the parks
everything operated by tokens
drop in a token go on the swing set drop
in another token take a walk drop in a
token look at a duck i couldn't care
less about the commendation
but indianapolis is home to charles
mulligan's steakhouse the best damn
steakhouse in the damn state i have
taken a picture of every steak i've ever
eaten there june 2004 porterhouse medium
rare bearnaise sauce january 2000 they
call this one the enforcer february 96
the steak rib eye the whiskey lagavulin
16. the lady next to me a [ __ ]
specifically my ex-wife tammy okay this
is this is the first time i ever went
there
look at me
just a kid
i just want to get the work over as soon
as possible so i can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me it's like yoga
except i still get to kill something
i am only here because i owe leslie a
thousand favors i'm not big on charities
give a man a fish and you feed him for a
day
don't teach a man to fish and you feed
yourself
he's a grown man fishing's not that hard
no i don't plan to buy anything here i
buy my burger ingredients at food and
stuff a discount food outlet equidistant
for my home and my work
i came here for the same reason people
go to the zoo
look at that thing
nature is amazing
behold
the swanson pyramid of greatness i've
been developing the swanson pyramid of
greatness for years it's a perfectly
calibrated recipe for maximum personal
achievement
categories include capitalism god's way
of determining who is smart and who is
poor crying acceptable at funerals and
the grand canyon rage poise property
rights fish for sport only not for meat
fish meat is practically a vegetable
haircuts there are three acceptable
haircuts high and tight crew cut buzz
cut are the scissors broken in your
house son
history began on july 4th 1776.
everything before that was a mistake
diane suggested we tag along to london
for a honeymoon i agreed because my love
for her trumps my hatred for europe
then she hit a phase of morning sickness
that knocked her for a loop and decided
to stay home but she insisted i go and
take pictures for her all of this could
have been avoided if we'd followed my
plan for a honeymoon a steak dinner a
glass of lagavulin whiskey then vigorous
lovemaking for two hours and we're both
asleep by 8 30. the less i know about
other people's affairs the happier i am
i'm not interested in caring about
people
i once worked with a guy for three years
and never learned his name
best friend i ever had
we still never talk sometimes
on my deathbed my final wish is to have
my ex-wives rush to my side so i can use
my dying breath to tell them both to go
to hell one last time
would i get married again oh absolutely
if you don't believe in love what's the
point of living
ann was getting a little chummy
when people get too chummy with me
i like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know i don't really care about
them that's a genius move thank you
you're welcome
lester
every summer leslie throws a barbecue to
thank the parks and maintenance staff
it's horrifying barbecues should be
about one thing
good shared meat
leslie needs to butt out the whole point
of this country is if you want to eat
garbage balloon up to 600 pounds and i
have a heart attack at 43 you can
you are free to do so
to me that's beautiful for the last
three years i have served as troop
leader of the pawnee rangers this is our
handbook
i wrote the whole thing myself
tom and april were excellent witnesses
in my defense
unfortunately every single word out of
their miles was a lie there's only one
thing i hate more than lying
skim milk which is water that's lying
about being milk
either we complete a government project
which is abhorrent to me or we bring a
new person into the department which
repulses me to my core reminds me of
when my dad made me choose which of my
pet calves to slaughter with my own
hands for my sixth birthday
i couldn't choose so i slaughtered both
of them
and they were delicious i'm impressed
with andy pulling himself up by his
bootstraps
reminds me of me i got my first job when
i was nine worked at a sheet metal
factory in two weeks
i was running the floor
child labor laws are ruining this
country computers are mostly pointless
but that yelp thing gave me a great idea
on how to criticize people in places
i am composing strongly worded letters
about things i disapprove of and i am
using the internet to get addresses
where i can send them so far i've
written to a vegetable farm several
european ambassadors a manufacturer of
male cologne and a non-fat frozen yogurt
bar
dear frozen yogurt you are the celery of
desserts be ice cream or be nothing
zero stars
i'm a simple man
i like pretty dark-haired women and
breakfast food but this stock photo i
bought at a framing store isn't real
today i got the real thing
a naked tammy made me breakfast this
morning
i should have taken a picture of it
i enjoy government functions like i
enjoy getting kicked in the nuggets with
a steel-toed boot
but this hotel always serves
bacon-wrapped shrimp
that's my number one favorite food
wrapped around my number three favorite
food i'd go to a banquet and honor those
somali pirates if they serve
bacon-wrapped shrimp excuse me these
people are soft they're grilled virgins
but by the time this day is over
they'll have been taken by the grill and
delicately and tenderly shown the ways
of flavorful meat love
the first time is so beautiful
metaphors i hate metaphors that's why my
favorite book is moby dick
no frou-frou symbolism just a good
simple tale about a man who hates an
animal does the white whale actually
symbolize the unknowability and
meaninglessness of human existence
yeah no it's just a fish
i will walk deeper into the belly of the
beast if it means i'm able to further
limit reckless government spending i
mean i have so many ideas
some are simple like take down traffic
lights and eliminate the post office the
bigger ones will be tougher like
bring all of this crumbling to the
ground normally if given a choice
between doing something and nothing i
choose to do nothing but i will do
something if it helps someone else do
nothing i'd work all night if it meant
nothing got done when i walked in this
morning and saw the flag was at
half-mast i thought
all right another bureaucrat ate it
but then i found out it was little
sebastian
half-mast is too high
show some damned respect
no home is complete without a proper
toolbox here's april and andy's
a hammer
half of a pretzel baseball card some
cartridge that says sonic and hedgehog a
scissor half and a flashlight
filled with jelly beans
i love food and stuff
it's where i buy all of my food
and most of my stuff
all my life i have avoided europe and
its multitudes of terribleness but it
turns out much to my surprise there is
actually one place in europe that is
worth seeing
[Music]
these tiny islands off the coast of
scotland where god's chosen elixirs are
distilled barreled and prepared for
consumption
this
is worth the trip
dear ron
you have now reached the cliffsides
overlooking the islands
as you sit here and gaze upon the waters
please read out loud the poem by the
great scotsman robert burns love leslie
a worm i love yon lilac fair with purple
blossoms to the spring
and i a bird to shelter there
when wearied on my little wing
how i would mourn when it was torn
by autumn wild and winter rude
but i would sing on wanton wing
when youthful may it's bloom renewed
[Music]
i don't know what she thought i'd get
out of that
[Music]
you